foreign
[Music]
belongings gone in seconds
this landslide in Peru's southern
arakipa region swept away everything in
its path
villagers who Moved uphill could only
watch as hundreds of their homes were
washed away
familiar significance there are over a
thousand affected families we can say
that the houses of 90 percent of
affected families were completely
destroyed foreign
[Music]
some bodies have been retrieved from the
debris many are believed to be miners
four Villages were the hardest hit they
are in an area called Nicholas valcusel
where it's rained continuously for
several days
there are no houses this is a complete
disaster we've got corpses scattered
everywhere they're dead
hey
many people are still missing officials
in the city of array keeper are asking
the national government to declare a
state of emergency
[Music]
the Army has been deployed to help
Southern regions like array keeper were
a starting point for major protests
after the arrest and dismissal in
December of then president Pedro
Castillo
as well as a political crisis and a
slowing economy Peru now faces a natural
disaster
foreign